At a pristine lake in Ontario, Canada, scientists
had been adding low levels of estrogen to
the lake and were watching for changes. The
levels were approximately equal to the concentration
of estrogen found in treated sewage discharge.
The result: fathead minnow populations began
to collapse!
Many of the chemicals that we use and release,
whether on purpose or by accident, can have
severe effects on organisms and ecosystems.
To predict the accumulation and levels of
contaminants, we can use differential equations.
This video is part of the Differential Equations
video series.
Laws that govern a system's properties can
be modeled using differential equations.
Hi, my name is David Griffith, and I'm a graduate
student in the MIT/Wood's Hole Joint Program
in Oceanography and the Department of Civil
and Environmental Engineering at MIT.
Before watching this video, you should be
familiar with defining control volumes and
applying conservation of mass.
After watching this video, you will be able
to: Construct a differential equation to estimate
the concentration of a chemical in the environment;
and Appreciate how informed estimates can
help simplify and solve these differential
equations.
While everyday chemicals provide a range of
benefits to society, they are often released
into the environment and can cause unintended
harm.
Examples include acid rain from smokestack
sulfur emissions, toxic groundwater from leaky
gas station tanks, and endocrine disruption
in fish populations due to treated and raw
sewage discharges.
It would be helpful if we could monitor the
levels of potentially hazardous chemicals
in the environment. But, given the tens of
thousands of chemicals in daily use, it shouldn't
be surprising that measuring all of them is
not practical.
So, what we need is a framework for simplifying
a very complex world. We accomplish this through
the use of mathematical models, which are
simplified versions of reality.
Many models take the form of differential
equations, which describe how one variable,
like the concentration of a chemical, changes
with respect to another variable, like time.
By applying conservation of mass, we can model
the change in chemical concentration with
time as being equal to the inputs minus the
outputs. An input is the rate at which a chemical
enters our control volume. An output is the
rate at which the chemical leaves the control
volume.
To find the inputs and outputs of chemicals
into a control volume, the first step is to
identify the ways that chemicals enter and
leave the control volume.
If we think about the estrogen experiment
in Ontario, the estrogen entered the lake
from the scientist intentionally dumping estrogen
from a motorboat and from the fish themselves.
Once released into the lake, there are many
ways estrogens can leave the lake. A stream
could carry the estrogens out of the lake.
Also, physical, chemical, and biological processes
within the lake could degrade the estrogens
to inactive byproducts.
In my own research, I am interested in the
fate of estrogens in the treated sewage that
is discharged into Massachusetts Bay.
To start, I had two initial questions:
1) would the estrogen levels in the bay be
high enough to detect with our instruments?
And
2) how much water would I need to collect?
To answer these questions, I needed to estimate
the concentration of estrogen in the bay.
This is where the differential equation comes
in. We can set up the equation by setting
the time change in estrogen concentration
(dC/dt) equal to inputs minus outputs.
Note that our definition of outputs includes
both physical flows and chemical reaction
rates. What are the possible inputs? Because
Massachusetts Bay receives 360 million gallons
of treated sewage discharge from the city
of Boston every day, we can assume here that
sewage is the dominant input.
Now, can you think of any removal processes
(that is, outputs) besides water leaving the
bay? Pause the video here and write down a couple.
There are many possible outputs, including
the rates of dilution, sedimentation, biodegradation,
loss to the atmosphere, and photodegradation.
Observe that some of these estrogen outputs
remove estrogens from the control volume,
while others chemically transform estrogens
into other compounds.
At this point we may decide to neglect terms
that we suspect will be small given what we
know about the characteristics of the particular
chemical and environment that we're modeling.
For example, we might neglect loss to the
atmosphere because estrogen's structure means
it has a low vapor pressure.
In addition, the fact that sewage is discharged
from a pipe at the seafloor and will be trapped
below the sunlit surface allows us to neglect
photodegradation.
We include the inputs and outputs into the
differential equation like so.
We're going to make two more simplifying assumptions
to make this equation easier to solve. Remember,
the goal is not to have a perfect model of
estrogens in the bay, but to make a quick
computation to estimate how much water I should
collect before I will have levels of estrogen
that I can detect.
The two simplifying assumptions we make are
that: 1. The distribution of estrogens in
the control volume is uniform. That is, the
bay is "well mixed. 2. The concentration is
constant in time, that is the inputs and outputs
are balanced. We could solve this equation
without assuming that the concentration is
constant in time, but this would make our
solution a lot more complex, so for OUR back
of the envelope calculation, this is OK.
Let's look at the terms in our differential
equation. The input rate is represented by
the mass flux, which is the mass per time,
Q, of estrogen leaving the wastewater treatment
plant, divided by the volume, V, of the bay.
Dilution rate is represented by the dilution rate constant K dilution times C.
Sedimentation rate is determined in terms
of the concentration of estrogens that are
attached to solid particles, since only the
estrogen on solid particles will sink.
Keep in mind that the solid particle estrogens
are represented by some fraction fs of the
total concentration.
So the sedimentation rate is represented by
the sedimentation rate constant, k_sed, times
the fraction of the concentration of estrogen
attached to solid particles.
Biodegradation rate is represented by the
biodegradation rate constant k_deg times C.
Assuming steady state we get this equation.
Grouping like terms, and solving for C we
get this.
Now we can isolate C and solve the equation
using what we know or can estimate about the
chemical or the system.
Once we solved for the concentration of estrogen
in the bay, we determined that we needed to
collect 20 liters of water in order to make
the necessary measurements.
Here you see me on Massachusetts
bay collecting water samples.
We would collect 8 samples of 20L of water
per day, extract and concentrate each sample
down to 100 micro liters before high enough
levels of estrogens could be experimentally
measured using a mass spectrometer. The model
was key in helping me plan my sampling strategy.
It turns out that this quick estimate was
pretty good, and I've collected and was able
to detect estrogens in Massachusetts bay.
Now I can use these measurements to refine
my model. For example, I might remove the
assumption that the concentration is unchanging
in time.
By comparing measured and predicted concentrations,
we can also hypothesize about which processes
are dominant and discover potential missing
processes that affect estrogen concentration
in the bay.
Once these hypotheses are well formed, we
can then design new experiments to test them.
And can continue to refine the model.
Ultimately, it's the iterative process of
taking measurements and refining our model
that allows us to answer important questions
about whether estrogen levels are likely to
pose a hazard in the bay.
We have demonstrated how differential equations
and simplifying assumptions can be used to
help us predict the concentration of a contaminant
in a coastal bay. We have shown a simple example,
but the approach can be applied to any chemical
in any control volume and at any scale. So,
the next time you are marveling at the complexity
of the world around you, you can imagine how
you might construct a model using differential
equations to help you understand it better.